So, um, I just finished
the book over the weekend.
Um,
and I really appreciated all the stories,
right? Like you, you have been, you know,
a firsthand participant and talk to,
uh, lots of other people who were about
like the evolution of this from, you know,
kind of a crazy idea that,
you know,
a handful of small teams
worked on and, and, uh, it's,
I really loved all the stories and just
getting to know the peoples, you know,
someone you might hear about in the news
and I just love the way he's told the
story. So I thought, um, since
you know, this is where at Google,
this is a book about the driverless car.
Maybe a fun story to jump into would be
to tell everybody a little about your
first ride in the chauffeur car.
Happy to do that. And thanks everybody
for coming today. It's a real pleasure.
It's a pleasure to be part of your
team. Actually. Um, I was, um, uh,
General Motors until 2009,
um,
we had competed in the Darpa
urban challenge in 2007. You know,
that was a race of robotic cars and the
first prize was $2 million and Jim was
starting to hit the wall at that time.
So I figured we needed the money,
we better go out and win this race.
But we sponsored a Carnegie Mellon's team
and Chris Urmson who subsequently led
this program for Google self driving cars,
um,
reached out to me after I left Gm.
They were looking for a gray
beard auto executive that could,
could help them out. So
I came out in 2010. Uh,
the deal was I'd come out and talk to
them if I could ride in the car and they
had 13 Prius's.
Um,
and it was remarkable progress
because at the urban challenge,
we had a Chevy Tahoe sport utility vehicle
that was just loaded with hardware.
I mean,
you could,
you could barely squeeze one person into
the vehicle and by the time they were
doing the testing in 2009 and 10,
they had it in a press.
Most of all the hardware was
in the trunk of the Prius,
plus the sensors on the outside.
So at that time you could write
on one on one in the vehicle. Um,
and it's a basically an expressway.
So I drove the car out.
I had a technician next to
me in the passenger seat
and I had an engineer in the
back seat and I had a big red panic button
on the council. So this is, you know,
too late 2010 early
2011 and they said okay,
just to engage it like
you would cruise control.
I was in the Middle Lane of the freeway
and my hands are shaking over the
steering wheel. My feet are shaking, I
think, and this is crazy, but you know,
once I engaged it,
within about a couple minutes,
Jeremy has started feeling natural.
The car was intuitive.
Even at that point in time a Volkswagen
beetle came up on my left and cut in
front of me and I
realized the car I was in,
it already backed off and started to
create a gap for that vehicle to get into.
And you would never be able
to do that as a driver.
This technology has like eagle eye vision
with eyes in the back of your head.
Later on,
a big semi truck came up on my right and
sure enough my car was nudging over a
bit.
But when I found so fascinating was after
the first 10 minutes it was so relaxed.
I wasn't even worried about weather
traffic backed up in front of man.
I never thought about jumping to the
right lane or left lane to get in front of
someone. It just took all the road
rage and stress out of driving.
So I was sold and that that was a
remarkable accomplishment and just a real
testament to how good this team was
that you had a Google self driving cars.
Yeah, it was, it was really
striking to hear the, the I,
there's a story you tell about I think
riding in one of the early Carnegie
Mellon cars.
Yeah.
Yeah. Well, I, um,
because general motors was the
sponsor of the Carnegie Mellon boss,
we call the boss of the Chevy Tahoe.
And I thought it was important that I,
being head of R and d go out and put in
an appearance and get to know the team.
We had some of our engineers
embedded with the team.
And so I went out and they had it
out on a test track, which was, um,
a real old like steel plant that it,
then they sort of just sort of
grabbed it and started using,
I don't even know if they
had permission to do it,
but it was rutted roads and everything.
And they were showing me how the vehicle
would operate autonomously. And I said,
well, I'd like a ride in it. And he
kind of looked at me and it's found,
they didn't say no, but I said, yeah,
I really would like to write on it.
So they squeezed me in that one other
area that you could fit into. Well,
this vehicle wasn't designed for a human,
this vehicle was designed to
win a self driving car race.
So it accelerated very aggressively.
Stopped very aggressively cornered very
aggressively and within about 30 seconds
I'm getting so carsick and they're all
laughing about this because they really
put one over on me. But that
was an important point. Um,
the Carnegie Mellon team felt that
by being an aggressive driver,
we were more like an x games
athlete in this competition.
We knew Stanford was going to be more
like I'm a figure skater and they were
going to have a really
smooth, nice, precise vehicle.
But we knew enough about the race that
we thought we could pick up six minutes
but accelerating hardened braking hard
and we won the race by 20 minutes.
So that was an important part of our,
yeah. You mentioned a writing in the
chauffeur car the first time you,
you pretty quickly,
we're relaxed and not worried about
things and you sorta comment that they're
actually, you know, there,
there are different strategies being
pursued in the marketplace today about,
you know, like how do, how
do we deploy this technology,
how do we bring it to a mass audience?
And one is kind of this
driver assist version that um,
and, and the other is more of a service
and he kind of observed that. Um,
what'd you say?
I think that uh,
the driver assist version says you
don't need to pay attention to the road
except that because it's an assistant,
it also says you need to be paid paying
attention at all times in order to take
over. And I want, if you want
to comment a little, yeah,
no, the Google self driving car team
I think may two really big decisions.
They've made a lot of great decisions,
but early on they made the decision that
they wanted to create a car that didn't
rely on what's called vehicle to
vehicle or vehicle to infrastructure
communication.
So a lot of people on this field thought
that if you get cars talking to each
other,
they could avoid each other.
But I think the Google self driving car
came realize that you'd have to have all
cars capable and would take
forever to get to that point.
They also believe because of your
background mapping and because of their
knowledge of the sensors that they could
actually do a standalone self driving
car. And, and, and that
was critically important.
They began to develop this technology
that I experienced on the freeway and they
thought maybe they could do an initial
product called the highway assist.
And they did a dog fooding a exercise
with the local mountain view.
Google employees ask them to
use the vehicle on weekends.
They had a promise to pay
attention to their driving,
but they could take you to lake
Tahoe and stuff alone. And behold,
within the first few weeks we realized
that that these people were totally
distracted.
One individually even fell asleep and you
would never been able to reengage them
if something came up. Uh, and uh,
the Daniel Fairfield on the team,
he reached an important conclusion, I
think shared with all of us. He said,
you know,
if we always keep the driver in the loop,
we're never going to be
safer than the driver.
90% of the crashes are due to human error.
So they concluded these driver assist.
Jeremy was not consistent with their goal,
which was to eliminate car crashes all
together and made the second really
important decision that their commitment
was to totally autonomous where a
person would never be asked to take over.
Now you can imagine what a challenge
that is because you have to discover all
those really unusual things that happen
in everyday driving or every year
driving that long tail.
And that's part of what's going on
right now is this continued learning.
But it's also part of the reason why
Waymo has such a head start on everyone
because they,
they've been doing this a long time and
they've accumulated a lot of experience.
I was curious, you know, as far as
reducing the fatality rate, I checked,
it sounds like,
um,
there's little over one fatality per
hundred million miles driven or something.
So to get a sense on whether really safer,
does that mean we need to get
a few hundred million miles?
These cars you have have two or,
and I would say an supplement that
with AI and machine learning and great
simulation models.
So you know,
this isn't about any one sensor.
It's not about anyone enabling technology.
It's this combination of maps,
sensors,
onboard processor of software,
and then in the development process to
be able to go out there and capture a lot
of, when you encounter
something unusual on the road,
bring that back to the lab and simulate
it virtually simulate it in reality and
learn about the edge cases and
get confident that you've dealt,
not just with the unusual thing that
you observed. So take traffic circles,
for example. We've all, you've all
probably been in a traffic circle.
Have you been in two lane traffic circles
or three lane traffic circles and do
you have to capture everything about all
of those in the real world or can you
model that and get to the edge
cases and move yourself forward?
Yeah, I hadn't thought about that. So
it's a part of it is real world driving.
Part of it is taking the data you've
collected from strives and simulating and
that gets us closer to
those hundred millions.
So, so you say, why am I my,
my Google get into this? Um,
I think because we're not a car company,
but extraordinary deep knowledge
of computer science, uh,
and um, and robotics, you know,
the best surfers in the world,
the best mapping system in the world,
great AI teams,
and it's really a shift,
fundamental shift.
And what are the core
competencies required to be a
leader and transportation in
the future versus the historic
once in the historic ones,
which recover quite a bit on the book.
Really like 130 years of
history of combustion based
vehicles that are energized
by oil that are human controlled
with the controls being hydraulic and
electronic primarily.
And those competencies were
about combustion and the
driver interface to get the
ultimate driving machine.
And we're going to have in the future
of the ultimate writing machines,
not the ultimate driving machine.
So this is a profound shift and the
fundamental competencies to be a leader in
transportation.
Yeah, yeah. I think you, you know,
you sort of explained that there are
three trends that are coming together,
right? There's the, the software
and the driverless technology, um,
and there's electric vehicles
which have some advantages.
They're much easier for software
to control then all mechanical one.
And then there's this idea of
transportation as a service rather than,
you know,
personal ownership.
And those are like the three factors
that are all coming together.
Yeah. Yeah. They bought come together.
Two of them are really technology enabled
on the other one has a business model
innovation. So again,
it's not about one thing,
it's about several things
combining at the same time.
I'd like to call that the power of
an that's the connecting of the dots.
And here's Kinda how this, this logic
goes. When you have an autonomous vehicle,
suddenly you don't need to pay a person
to drive the vehicle and reposition it.
And um, that makes selling
transportation as a service,
a pretty compelling opportunity because
you've lowered the cost then of getting
high utilization out of the vehicle.
So it can pick me up,
take me to my destination, dropped me
off, and then without any labor costs,
go a couple blocks and pick up and take
you to your destination or drop you off
and keep doing that throughout the day.
And you get very high utilization
of that fleet. Uh, today,
most cars are used about
12,000 miles a year,
or these transportation service business
model suggested would be 75,000 miles a
year.
The cars are parked 90 to 95% of the time.
What I just described means the vehicle
is in route to pick you up rather than
being parked,
but what you,
what you do then is because it's
autonomous and it's a service you want to
optimize the cost per mile.
The car industry has been focused on
optimizing the price of a new car at a
dealership when you go there and
fall in love with it to buy it.
When you optimize the cost per mile,
it turns out electric drive is a really
good deal because of fleet optimized
costs per mile.
You want the vehicle last about 300,000
miles and electric drive can save you
five to 10 cents a mile.
That's 15,000 to $30,000
over the lifetime,
which is more than enough to pay
for the electric drive still.
The funny thing about this
is it's autonomous vehicles.
I think that's going to get us past the
tipping point for electric vehicles,
not to make this story even better.
80% of the trips we make as Americans
are one and two person trips,
but our cars aren't.
Trucks are designed way over
designed for the occasional trip.
When you tailor designed this
autonomous electric vehicle for this
transportation service and
the most typical trips,
it probably wants to be a two
person vehicle is probably
going to have about one
10th as many parts in it
as a conventional car.
And that is really important to
understand if you're in the car industry.
So it's, it's, it's the
simplicity of electric drive.
You don't have transmissions,
you don't have exhaust systems,
you have gasoline tanks,
you don't have all those mechanical parts
in the engine moving and you get rid
of all the parts with a driver interface.
So boom, it's really transformational.
One of the stories that actually it
was one of my favorite in the book,
I think it was when,
uh,
Byron Mccormick brought you out to
the vehicle assessment center and he,
you know,
he sort of showed you that maybe you want
to describe what that was like. Yeah,
yeah. Um, and in 1988,
I was asked to lead an initiative at
GM called design for manufacturing and,
um,
you know,
we had a lot of different products and
our cars just seem like they were harder
to put together than our competitors.
And so we decided to tear
apart or competitors, cars,
lay out all the parts and then conceive
of how they're building their cars.
And Lo and behold,
we were way a uncompetitive.
So this tear down sooner
became an important place
for a lot of the leaders at
GMB begin to visualize what was going
on by Ren Maccormack who reported to me
was one of the best technologists
I've ever worked with. He had, uh, uh,
ran the battery plant for GMC [inaudible].
He was one of the pioneers of what's
now called stability control. Um,
but very importantly he led
our fuel cell program as well.
And Byron and his team conceived of what
we call a vehicle called [inaudible]
flux, which was based on these principles
of electric motors in the wheels,
energy storage and the platform,
almost like a skateboard.
And then by wire steering,
by wire breaking and really
optimized around software.
And you went ahead and prototyped that
and laid out all the parts in a torn down
way,
in the same place where he took apart a
Chevy Malibu and they took about a Prius
and lay those parts out with a Prius,
had more parts than a Malibu
cause it was a hybrid.
But the flex have radically fewer,
I mean you could really see where the
industry was going to had when it was
going to be an electrical and
electronically controlled.
So we brought my boss Rick Wagner and
who is the chairman and CEO of GM.
He had to see this and he,
he got it.
He understood it wasn't just all the fewer
parts because the parts that you have
to design,
engineer released manufacturer tool,
they drive the cost
structure of a car company,
but it was also was the software
and that was just so important.
And it's I think a lesson out of that as
when you have an idea and you're trying
to communicate it,
getting to rapid prototyping and making
it visible for a lot of people I think
really helps get your idea communicated.
Yeah. Yeah. I love, I love the
visual of seeing, you know, the,
the car exploded and all the
parts of the Malibu and then, uh,
the electric vehicle with
radically fewer parts.
That's just a great way
to get your point across.
Um, that, uh, one of the other things I
found fascinating and I said, you know,
it sounds like maybe 2010,
2011,
I think you were at Columbia and you
were kind of modeling how this would work
and I think you picked Ann Arbor and a
few other cities and found that, you know,
like you can offer this
service with actually not
that many cars relative to the
number of cars that people actually,
you know,
park in their driveways in Ann Arbor.
Yeah.
There was a famous economics professor
at Columbia named Jeff Sachs and he had
written the book end of poverty and he
was running an institute called the Earth
Institute. And when GM was going
bankrupt, he came and visited us. And um,
I gave him an overview of some of the
thinking we have longer term and Jeff and
I hit it off and when I left GM he asked
me if I would leave Columbia's program
for a sustainable mobility,
which, which I decided to do.
And what we were really interested in is,
no kidding.
What would city looked
like if you combined tailor
designed vehicles for the two
person,
one person trip with electric drive that
are autonomous and importantly shared,
how many would you need to meet all the
transportation requirements of a city
and how much would it cost?
And so we decided to model this and
at that time there was a really neat
database. It was a 2009 a household travel
surveys from the federal government.
And it gave us a good idea of how many
cars were in cities like Anarbor Austin
or Columbus, Ohio, Rochester,
New York, Manhattan, uh,
Palm Beach County, Florida. So we
sat down and started to model this.
And um,
there were 200,000 cars in Anarbor,
about 120,000 of them stayed
within the metropolitan area.
And our modeling came back and said we
could get all of the trips that those
cars are making done with 15,
18,000 shared vehicles,
just 15% of the cars that were there.
We thought we had to be wrong because at
the same time we concluded we could get
to the customers quickly within minutes.
And that the fleet would be highly
utilized. And we kept studying this,
convinced we didn't have it right,
but finally we understood the population
density of places like Ann Arbor was
high enough such that the trip frequency
throughout the 14 busy hours of the day
was high enough such that just after
they'd drop me off somewhere in Anarbor.
Sure enough there was a high probability
someone a couple blocks away was
requesting a ride. And that's
how the math worked out and that,
that was the moment. And then when we
said what would this cost, you know,
the electricity costs, the
insurance, the cost of the vehicle,
d being depreciated finance costs,
both your time cost and
out of pocket costs.
We thought we could get to something
on the order of 20 cents a mile.
And that's compared to
owning and operating a card
about a dollar 50 including
your time cost.
So you,
but you bounced that against
the 3 trillion miles a
year that Americans drive.
And that's a $4 trillion disruption.
And that, that was a pretty big Aha.
And we went about getting that
story told and it was a lot of fun.
Yeah.
And so how much did that for four and a
half trillion dollars is spent on fossil
fuels?
Well, um, uh, it's,
we use about 180 billion gallons
of gasoline a year. So, you know,
three bucks, I'd say
about a 500, 500 billion.
Yeah. Yeah. So, you
know, if this works out,
it's going to really significantly.
Very significantly. Yeah. And an
interesting irony is sad irony about that.
As the year General Motors went bankrupt,
um,
embarrassingly we lost $32 billion.
Exxon Mobil may $45 billion that year.
Oil prices has gone to a
dollar 60 a barrel. I'm sorry,
I'm sorry, $160 a barrel and come
to 160 and they made $45 billion.
That was the highest profit ever made
by a company at that point in time.
And the sad thing about that oil
consumption is when you refine it to make
gasoline and you burn it
in a combustion engine,
about 75% of that energy is 70.
Let's say 75 to 80%,
it gets lost as heat and friction
and sound, that kind of a thing.
So about 20 to 30% crates torque
that turns the wheels of the car,
the car's way, three to 4,000 pounds and
people were, you know, 120 to 200 pounds,
Jeremy.
The bottom line is just one to 2% of
the energy and that gallon of gasoline
moves you the driver.
And here's this company
that makes $45 billion. Uh,
and the only way Exxon
Exxonmobil could have done that.
That's because GM was in the business
of building and selling cars that relied
on oil.
Yeah, yeah. That's a,
it's a disruption in a lot of ways.
Well, it's a huge, it's a huge disruption.
It's a disruption to the people
who drive for a living and,
and uh,
I understand that and I respect that.
If my professional was
being disrupted by this,
I don't think I would feel
comfortable about that. But,
and also it's a disruption to the auto
industry because far fewer parts mean far
fewer employees, um, in the supply base.
And at the original equipment
manufacturer and base,
but also far fewer engineers cause
you have to design fewer parts.
It's a disruption to the
corner gas station operator
because these vehicles will
be supplied probably through fleets.
By the way,
you could have one for your dedicated use.
Please don't think the only solution
here is a shared vehicle like an Uber
without our driver.
You certainly can subscribe to one and
have it for your own personal dispatch
desires. But at the end of the day, you're
not going to want to stop to refuel it,
a recharge it.
So this recharging is going to be done
at a depot and out of the corner gas
station.
And the beauty of that is that lets us
introduce alternatives to oil without
having to have 170,000 gas stations.
So you pull that string
parking gets impacted,
dealers get impacted, land, juice
and real estate gets impacted.
The entire economy gets
impacted quite frankly.
Yeah, it's uh, it's,
it's fascinating to sort of enter
into that analysis in the book.
I was also thinking we're
here in New York City. Uh,
so I think the recent news is that the
city is considering putting a limit on
the number of Uber and Lyft
drivers. Uh, and, and sort of,
I'm like,
I wonder what your take on that sort
of policy issue in the short term is,
you know what?
Well, I, you know, I, I believe, um,
it's an important issue because you have
an awful lot of people out there trying
to make money as a,
as an Uber driver and there needs to be
this balance between supply and demand.
And if you have too many people out there
and not enough customers are going to
have more cars on the road, not really
creating value. So that's problematic.
I do worry about governments thinking
they can regulate that rather than the
market finding that right balance.
So I am concerned about that.
When you do get to driverless cars,
um,
your whole goal will be to have high
fleet utilization because that's key to
making money.
You're going to optimize the size
of your fleet so that you have high
utilization, low empty miles and
fast response times. And, um,
so I don't think that carries over to
the driverless discussion. Fortunately,
the regulators at the local state and
federal level for driverless cars have
that.
The only way we're going to get to this
goal of fully driverless is to learn on
public roads. So they haven't stepped
up and said, you can't do this.
And that's by the way, that's
a big difference between
general motors and Google.
Um, uh, Sebastian Thrun and
Chris Urmson in their team,
when they started their project,
they wanted to learn on public roads.
And so they wondered if they could do
it in the law in California said you
needed to have a driver
in the driver's seat.
It didn't say you needed to
touch the steering wheel,
the brake feller or the accelerator.
So they just went off and did it.
My General Council term owners would
say, no way, you can only test in a,
in a proving ground. So they had
to get on public roads and this,
this is a technology,
you think about that you eliminate
90% of the crashes in the world.
There's 1.3 million people a year dying
on the world's roadways that is epidemic
and scale. Get rid of 90% of that.
That's a million lives a year.
Divide that by 365.
That's 3000 lives a day.
If we get to this end goal one day sooner,
we're going to save 3000 lives.
So I think the biggest risk is not
moving fast enough and the regulators
fortunately haven't said stop,
haven't said you can't learn on public
roads and, and we're making good progress.
We need to be open,
share the data and uh,
learn together. But I think we'll take
the journey and we'll get there, Jeremy.
I really do.
Yeah. It reminds me of a, of
another funny story in the book. Um,
I think from early on with the Carnegie
Mellon team that they were posting
videos,
uh,
on their blog of testing the
vehicle stopping and someone
somewhere on your team,
a middle manager saw it and thought,
oh my God,
I can't believe GM is funding this.
We got to put an end to it.
Yeah. Very, very different cultures. We,
we had a sad stretch in the late
eighties and early nineties of too many
fatalities in our plants.
These were our employees.
Maybe they had to do maintenance on
a robot and they didn't lock, lock,
lock out the robot and they got in there
and gotten electrocuted or something.
So we said, enough is enough. So we went
and benchmark the best in the world,
I'll call dupont. And we wanted to be the
benchmark, safest company to work for.
So safety was really ingrained
into everybody at GM. So
in this individual who,
who reported to me, so how our Carnegie
Mellon's team was just in the vehicles.
He felt it was way outside the
envelope on our safety culture and um,
felt we needed to shut down the program.
We worked through that.
Chris Urmson did a good job
with some diplomacy and a,
but really I can't overemphasize that
safety has to be the overriding priority
for, for any organization. And,
and I so admire what the Google self
driving car team has accomplished and
they've done it with a tremendous
safety culture. They've got this group,
we call it the ops group.
And the every morning they
shake down all of the cars,
make sure the curves physically
ready to go out on the road,
put their cell phones in their locker,
they go out and they're
highly trained people, um,
following standardized
processes and they really,
really take their job seriously.
Whenever,
if I ever have a chance to be in
the area where they work, you,
you almost feel like it's the same
discipline you would see and the military
operations, it's that serious
and it's paid off for us.
Waymo has had one APP for fault. Crash
was a two mile per hour fender bender.
We've had some others and,
and all those other cases,
it was the other driver with
the human driver that caused it.
Yeah. I'm curious about
it. Like, yeah. What,
what the limits of,
um,
unexpected things you can plan for our,
uh, um, thinking to a story from
the urban mobility challenge.
You know,
what happens if you're a autonomous
vehicle pulls up next to the jumbo tron in
that,
yeah. Staples, the GPS. This
was one of these, these moments,
the Carnegie Mellon and team, um,
had some challenges along the way.
The first race was in the desert
and part of their development work,
they rolled their homer,
which was her development vehicle
over and that caused some problem with
sensors. And we think that's why it only
went seven miles. And the second race,
Lo and behold,
they have the same thing happened.
They had two vehicles in that race,
the one that really was probably the
best vehicle and had a, a fuel, um,
or actually an electromagnetic
interference since we
found out later on damaged
and it was causing strange
things with the fuel. And um,
so the uh, lost my train of
thought. I can term it was okay.
I was thinking about the and
then in the urban mobility.
Oh yeah, yeah. And then in the
actual Darpa urban challenge,
um, we were the favorite. We thought
we were going to win this race.
We felt real good about all of our
tests and through the preliminary hates,
they sorted down to 14 finalists
and we were in the pole position.
And that meant we got to go out on the
track first and we couldn't get the gps
to calibrate something just
wouldn't lock in. And um,
everyone's panicking and they go to get
another GPS unit and it turns out ESPN
was covering the event and they had a
huge jumbo tron located right next to our
vehicle. And the person from the defense,
advanced research projects agency, Darpa,
who sponsored at Tony Tether said,
turn off the jumbo tron in
Cerner as they turned it off,
gps calibrated and we were back
in the race. So yes, there are,
those are learning things. Yeah. You know,
I dedicate this book to engineers
who make what's possible real.
How many of you here today or are
engineers or computer science or technical
backgrounds? I mean, that's
really what we do. And,
and I'm an engineer from the top of my,
to the tips of my toes.
And as long as the principles
of science are followed,
I think an engineer can accomplish almost
anything if you give them the right
learning cycles. But who would have
thought we would've had this interference?
But now we know. And, and
that's what this is all about.
Learning way out on the tail of the
distribution on, on learning cycles.
And that was one of those
great examples of learning.
Great example of what's going to
go wrong in the real world when we
yes, yes, things will go wrong
in the world, real world.
Sadly they go wrong and kill 40,000
Americans a year right now. And um,
I, I, I have to be really candid with you.
Every time I read about someone going
in the wrong way on the interstate and
having a head on killing four or five
people and just breaks my heart because I
know the technology
exists to prevent that.
And my daughters are 30 and 27 so I took
them through a driver's training and it
was an absolute nightmare to see
an inexperienced driver. I mean,
next time you do go through dry
through a busy intersection,
you're an experienced driver.
Think of what you're sorting out all of
the visual clutter that's there and what
you really have to pay attention to to
get through that intersection safely.
And now you take a 15 year old
kid who has never done it before.
It's learning curve. Jeremy and W
we've got to do better than this.
We absolutely have to do
better than those fatalities.
Yeah, yeah. I did like the,
the way you can contrast the sort of
the engineering cultures in Detroit and
Silicon Valley through the book and they,
you know,
and they each have their
strengths. And I think you, uh,
I'm pretty sympathetic to the, uh, the
Google software engineering culture,
but you pointed out how, um, you know,
maybe some of the Googlers
needed to come to terms with it.
The thing is Detroit is good at too.
Yeah.
The original title of the book was
the race to build the driver's car.
And um, uh, Alco who's our publisher or
the Dcis, who's the editor of surgeries,
he made one raise her hand, but she said,
maybe you are right at about the quest.
And that was really an important moment
for myself and Chris Shogun because
suddenly we realized, you know, maybe
this isn't silicon valley versus Detroit.
Maybe it's a bigger story than that.
Early on when I first arrived as the,
the gray haired executive
at Google self driving cars,
there was,
um,
I would say an arrogance and the team
about Silicon Valley being able to handle
these great world challenges at light
speed and the auto industry had lost its
way on innovation and really,
really was no longer imaginative.
It's the same time when
Chris Urmson and Anthony's,
I've endoscopy first went to Detroit
looking for car companies and suppliers to
collaborate with.
They basically threw them out the door,
thought they were irresponsible with
developing cars on public roads.
There's this tension between the silicon
valley culture and the Detroit culture
where the story stands now where
this quest stands now it's an end.
It's not an or. Um, I think by hiring
John Craft Chuck to lead Waymo,
it was a recognition by
alphabets leadership that
they needed somebody with a
lot of car experience to take this
forward and commercialize it. And,
and John was really, really
deepened his car experience. And at,
at at the same time,
I think Ford and General Motors realize
that they're going to have to reach out
to silicon valley to outsource that our
research and development and autonomous
vehicle system.
So GM acquired cruise automation and
then Argo AI was acquired by Ford.
So they've come together.
It's a Silicon Valley and Detroit
that will lead this forward.
Yeah,
quite fascinating.
I think another thing that kind of move
the story along with some, you know,
some combination of visionaries and,
and um,
and setting really audacious goals,
right?
These challenges both Darpa's
challenges and then, uh, uh, you know,
I guess Larry and Sergei
setting challenges with
Sebastian Thrun and others,
you know, like what, what
can you make happen here?
That's a great management principles,
setting stretch goals.
And when you're the person who has
to reach the stretch, stretch goal,
sometimes it can be a little bit
frightening, but think about it this way.
You could say your, um, you,
you want to accomplish something
on a scale of 10 and um,
you can set your,
your goal is six and get to
seven and feel good about it.
Or You could have set your goal at nine
and get the eight and not get there.
You'd rather be at eight than seven.
So stretch goal is an important principle.
The defense, advanced research
projects, agency, Darpa,
set stretch goals for the desert
challenge, which of which were two.
And then the goal for the urban challenge
with 60 miles in a city setting with
no one in the car,
no remote control,
obey all traffic laws and get it done
in six hours and nobody thought it could
be done.
So the Darpa challenge ends,
everybody's feeling great about it.
Tony Tether, the head of Darpa says,
mission accomplished.
Your guys have proven this can be done.
It's up to the commercial
sector to run with it.
And we all thought people would be falling
all over themselves wanting to take
the next step to make it commercial.
And nothing happened.
Caterpillar reached out and started
doing some work for mining applications.
But we wanted to change the
whole world of automobiles.
Larry and Sergei, we're the only
two leaders that stepped up.
Larry and Sergei, they
were at that race. Uh,
they had a passion for this subject
and Larry had a great conversation with
Sebastian Thrun and said,
Sebastian told Larry, we can't do this. We
shouldn't do it, Sebastian, until Larry,
I'm the best in this field. I know what
I'm talking about. We shouldn't get into.
And Larry said,
I have to tell Eric and Sergei a
real reason why we can't do it.
So he sends the bash and back the third
time and finally sabbatical came back,
said, well, maybe we can, and
then they set these stretch goals.
Think about this as a form of leadership.
Larry wanted it to go on
every road in California.
So they negotiated that they would
pick ten one hundred mile routes,
you know, who laid out the
routes, Larry and Sergei,
and they put a bonus in place for the
team to get this done in two years.
So to Sebastian negotiates another goal
a hundred thousand miles on public roads
because they want to at least
get a little bit of payment.
This is really impressive leadership.
And then they stuck with the
team and the team got a done.
And so there's a management lesson here.
You have to set it far enough out
where it's really hard to get there,
but not so far out that it's impossible.
And they've subsequently put additional
goals on the Waymo team that they're
working really, really hard on
right now in Chandler, Arizona,
tied to do people like riding in
these cars. Can you do it safely?
Is there a business here?
All of that stuff.
But it's really a good
lesson in management.
Yeah. And I guess, uh, um,
Tony and Darpa had the,
the sort of the most challenging when he
really had to stick to his guns, right?
Because after the first urban challenge
or the first desert challenge was
supposed to be 150 miles and the
best card did what, seven. Yeah.
Miles.
And he had all this media stacked up at
the finish line and nobody got there.
So Tony goes to the finish line,
he says,
I got great news the next race and he
is on this date and the prize is $2
million.
He really driven it and this is a lot
of money for these young teams competing
for it.
Yeah. Yeah. I thought that was
a great story. Like, you know,
stick with this approach. Um, I was,
I was also curious as need to like the,
the engineering cultures are
coming to appreciate the, you know,
like what they have to offer each other.
But you also,
I think kind of made a point,
at least in Detroit, right? The,
there's actually a hierarchy
of engineering teams, right?
So that parts manufacturers and some of
the parts manufacturers are as big as
the, the auto companies
know, sell the brand name.
And so I sort of wonder what
kind of hierarchy are we
going to see in the future?
I, you know, is um, is Uber the brand
we're going to know or you know,
or lift or Waymo is it going
to be Toyota? Uh, you know,
is there gonna be a lot
of competition about that?
Oh, yes. There's going to be
competition. First of all,
there's a lot of different
use cases for these brands.
There's the use case of
Uber's lifts without drivers.
There's the use case of you basically
leasing an autonomous vehicle and having a
subscription service so that you're
controlling it. So think about that. You,
you say,
I want one of these for 12 months and
then I'm going to subscribe for 30,000
miles. It takes you to
work, drops you off,
you then it to go pick up your spouse,
take him or her to work and drops them
off and your spouse dispatches it to go
pick up your kid at school for soccer
practice and then mother-in-law for meals
on wheels.
So you may use this one dedicated vehicle
to the point where you don't need that
second and third car, but you're still
going to have that control that you have.
So you've got that use case. Don't forget
goods movement over the road trucking,
there's shortage of truck
drivers or truck drivers,
64 cents a mile and benefits and wages.
And um,
it's a tedious job.
It takes people away from their home.
So there's real value to be created there.
And then finally that last mile
of delivery, and I goodness,
I work out of my Home Office.
I've had two times where the ups truck
and Fedex truck where my driveway at the
same time I came home from golfing two
weeks ago I had nine boxes on my porch.
My wife has been busy.
She's a hairstylist.
She likes to get all this stuff over
the internet. But that last mile,
if you can get the driver out
of the local delivery system,
whether it's with drones or you name it,
so a wide range of use cases.
How are you going to
brand that is important.
What are the experiences you're going
to deliver is not just about going from
point a to point B and
getting there safely.
It's does a pick me up on my precise
location and drop me off precisely.
Is the ride so nice that when I get out
of the vehicle I feel better than when I
got into it. Can I get to more
places with brand a versus brand B?
That's going to be a basis of competition.
But the one place I think you want to
be beyond anything else in this future
ecosystem is to have the world's best
driver because that world's best driver
can plan every one of those use cases.
And it's typically more than half the
cost per mile that we incur today.
So that's a big opportunity.
Now,
does this play out in a Microsoft kind
of a business model or an intel inside
business model or an arm business model?
Those decisions haven't been made yet.
There's still a lot of work to
do before you start scaling.
I think the experiences are get branded.
I personally think the car companies
are going to have a tough time saying
Chevrolet is the right brand
for a mobility service.
I think that's going to
be a bit of a stretch.
So I think you're gonna see some
rebranding going on. It's going to be fun.
All right. It's a, it's
been great talking to you.
I think I have to let everyone else
ask them. Well thank you. Thank you.
Thank you for reading the book or
questions were excellent. And, um,
certainly when you're an author you love
it when someone will give you some of
your time over the weekend. It's really
nice, Jeremy, that he did that. The,
I had great fun to read. Great Story.
It just one thing for the Q and a. Um,
I lost my hearing 20 years ago.
I hear with cochlear implants and at
the same technologies, autonomous cars,
it's batteries and sensors and
software and all of that stuff.
I think I'll hear you fine, but if not,
Jeremy, oh, help me with the questions.
Go ahead. Hey Larry, thanks
for coming to talk to us.
I have a three year old at home
and uh, you know, I think
about in 13 years is going
to get his driver's license.
What are the odds that he's going
to get his driver's license?
No,
I think the odds are pretty low.
There's a lot of people who are
enthusiastic about driving and you know,
a hundred years ago there are
a lot of people enthusiastic,
a lot of horses and um, you
know, there's still horse racing.
There's still equestrian.
The important message right now is not
that we're going to say you can't drive,
but for a lot of people were going to say
you're going to get the accessibility,
mobility benefits of owning and
operating a car and not have to drive.
So your, your, your,
your child is going to be able to make
a choice by the time they're 15 or 16.
There's a lot of negatives with owning
and operating a car beyond the safety
rest, having a staff to a
gas, having to find parking,
having to get your car maintained,
having a shop for,
I'll have an insured and finance it and
you put all that together and you say,
man, that's a real hassle and this
industry has existed for a century,
assuming you're willing to do that
and pay 35,000 bucks for a car.
So I think that world's going to change
quite a bit. Thank you. Thank you.
Over here.
So I actually have two questions.
The first one is a big downside of
electric vehicles has always been distance
per charge.
Uh,
what about taking a trip in the world
that you are describing here? Uh,
how would I go from New York City to
buffalo to get some buffalo wings for the
weekend? How does that play into what
you're talking about, which is more, uh,
you know, daily travel,
commuting, they et cetera.
Yeah,
that's an exciting question.
The range of the batteries has
increased significantly. Lay,
the Chevrolet Bolt for example,
has about 230 mile range.
So we think the battery is sufficient
for the everyday community kind of usage
in this shared model going
between communities. Um,
you may have like a,
a range extender that you
could associate with this.
I'm almost like a pod
that snaps on the back,
that's extra battery just when you need
to make that trip that can extend your
range and extend your power to do that.
Uh,
I wouldn't totally rule out
hydrogen and fuel cells.
I wish I never uttered
the word fuel cell cars.
This is just a hydrogen batteries
and other kind of a battery.
But that's its real advantage as you
can fill up with hydrogen and have
significant range. I do think when
the, when the market's there, um,
we're going to have the solutions in place
to get you from a buffalo to New York
City if that's where you want to go.
One way ticket to buffalo though.
Ah, that's right. We can
plug it in when we get,
so we saw in the late nineties,
early two thousands with the Evie one.
For example, as you mentioned, the
effect of the oil and gas lobbies. Um,
and what,
and their effect on the saturation of
the electric vehicle as a whole in the
United States.
Has that changed at all?
Are we at the point where we're ready
to see a gas and oil cars off road or
are we still fighting that same battle?
I certainly can see a pathway to not
need oil any longer in the transportation
sector. I hesitated a bit. Um, diesel
is a really good way to move. Hey,
80,000 pound load.
So there may be some applications there,
but I think for about 80% of the
oil we can get off of that. Will we,
um, the thing that keeps me
up at night, quite honestly,
I think what's going to gate all of
those are those very powerful voices that
have a vested interest in the hundred
and 30 year old automobile roadway
transportation system. The easiest
thing to do in Washington DC is say no.
And these companies who have something
to lose from this are very good at
knowing how to say no.
So that does concern me.
But technologically I think we're there.
I think in terms of value proposition for
all of us living in our everyday lives,
I think where their business model,
uh,
investors wanting to put the money in
this new future rather than where we've
been,
I think we're there now.
It's just a matter of almost like
the baseball movie field of dreams.
If I build it, they will come and that's
why I'm so proud to be part of Waymo, uh,
as an advisor because that's what they're
doing in Chandler has approving this
thing out.
Cool.
Thank you. Thank you. Yes. Hi.
You mentioned that you view as sort of
this market is being very competitive and
I was just wondering how you think about
like network effects have like Uber and
Lyft.
Basically their entire business model
is just if you have all the drivers then
you have all the passengers and you
can, you know, be a monopoly I guess.
How do you think about what
the market will look like,
whether you've used a transportation
is centralizing and what,
like regulatory or other options.
Very important questions.
And one of the interesting part of
results from the work I did at Columbia,
not only did we get this 20 cent
per mile opportunity identified,
it turns out scale economies are reached
at about 10% of the miles driven in a
community.
What I mean by that as if I had a shared
fleet that I was running in Anarbor and
I had 10% market share and then I went
to 11% my cost per mile wasn't going down
anymore. The suggests that, um,
you don't need to have the entire market
in order to, to have scale and be,
and be competitive. With that said,
there's definitely network effects there.
There's definitely scaling
affects those learning affects.
I talk about having the
world's best driver.
One of the best ways to do that is to
be learning for more and more and more
vehicles on the road every day.
And when the beauty of a driverless cars,
when I learned something from one car,
I can put it on all the other
cars and make all of them safer.
When I learned something as a human
driver about how to do something better,
I have no mechanism for transferring
that to other human driver.
So these things are real important and
I think they're going to have to be
watched,
certainly not a reason not to go forward,
but they're going to have to
be managed for sure. Yeah.
Yes. Yeah. I'm very excited
about driverless cars
and the certainly there's
tremendous, uh, uh, future.
There's one thing that worries me about
its impact on freedom because a car was
the greatest vehicle for
freedom and opportunity. Uh,
ability to go someplace is
a great boon for humans.
With now the way the driverless cars are
being actual designed and implemented
means we depend on cloud services and
on provider of cloud services desired to
enable my trip.
Google decides not to map
certain area in the car as well,
not go to their Dra,
uh,
Google or better yet the government
decides that certain event is not good.
They can easily make cars
not go to that event.
And this is because we have no other way
of doing things other than through the
cloud servers. We don't
treat, we will, uh,
we will not really own anything
even if we buy the, uh,
the car.
Yeah.
So yeah, I mean, first of all,
the title of my book has autonomy
because I believe this future is going to
bring more freedom.
Um,
there was a lot of people today that
can't benefit from an owning and operating
an automobile.
There are two younger driver,
they're too old or they're not
capable physically to do it.
They can't afford it or
whatever it might be.
So we really think we're going to bring
more freedom to a lot more people with
this.
If the concern that you raised,
which is really kind of beyond
my area of expertise. I,
if you're concerned about that,
I encourage you to go out
and start working on it
because we want this to be an
enabler of much greater freedom
rather than a constraint or a freedom.
I think when you look at the hundred
year history of the auto industry,
a lot of that stuff was
playing out as well.
Where were you going to build the road
and where are we going to build a parking
lot? And um, who pays for
the roads and all of that.
And I think we have created an extensive
amount of uneven access and inequality
in our mobility systems.
I live north of Detroit in
our neighborhoods in Detroit,
still have a lot of poverty and these
people can break out of the cycle of
poverty because we don't
have any transportation
alternatives other than than a
car. And the car insurance
is off the charts expensive.
So all of this has to be
managed and talked about.
And I'd encourage that dialogue to
continue, I think. Great observation. Yes.
Hey,
I was wondering if you thought that the
influx of autonomous vehicles in cities,
uh, will result in cities becoming
more multimodal, more walkable,
bikeable more mass transit with first,
last mile,
or if you thought it would just increase
car dependence and creased the widening
of roads,
et cetera.
I think it's going to be the f the former.
I mean,
there's three parking spaces dedicated
to every car in the United States and
there's, you know, 250 million cars.
So that's a lot of parking and
that parking, um, constraints,
densification. Um, I do
want to make a point though,
only 26% of Americans live in cities.
53% of Americans live in suburbs and
that parking issue is even more severe
there.
Um,
I on the board of a real
estate development company
in Florida and we had a
parcel of land that we are developing
along eyes 75 south of Tampa,
St Petersburg.
And they ended up putting a,
um, um, Walmart on that site.
But the amount of land for parking was
twice the amount of land for the building.
And this is nuts.
And so I think this is an opportunity
to really drive densification.
And secondly,
the vehicles are dramatically
better at detecting pedestrians,
detecting bicyclists,
and taking a lot of the risk out of the
system for vulnerable road way users.
I sometimes talk about this. You've
heard the concept of secondhand smoke.
I'd like to talk about secondhand
physics for some reason.
There's a belief that somebody can drive
a 5,000 pound Cadillac as escalate I
one of the streets in Manhattan
and go 45 miles an hour.
And it's that second hand physics.
I mean, it's just kinetic energy.
So we've got to work through it.
But I,
I'm in the camp where I think we're
going to make cities more livable,
but very importantly, I think we're
going to improve suburbs a lot too.
So the whole driverless car thing seems,
reminds me a lot of the Internet
in the 1980s nineties, 90s,
a lot of innovation and exciting things.
One of the things that happened sort of
after that time in the Internet is we
discovered there's a lot
of malefactors out there.
And,
um,
one of the things that I haven't heard
anyone in this industry really talking
about too much is how do you defend,
uh,
and make secure your driverless car,
not only against the kind of attacks
that are already taking place against,
you know,
automated but driver full cars,
but against jamming or other kinds of
attacks on the sensors and things like
that, which, you know, nobody is
doing that now. It's wonderful.
Everybody's cooperating mostly, but
you know, that doesn't last forever.
Yeah. Yeah. Low cybersecurity area again,
is not my expertise.
I talked to people who understand a
better than I do and we've got a lot of
people working on that hard. It's not an
issue that's unique to driverless cars.
It also exists in human driven cars or
current curves are very vulnerable to be
hacked. It's, it's part of other
systems we use in our daily lives.
They are airline system and other things.
And so I assure the concern.
Um, but not to the, and I'm not
implying you're suggesting this,
but not to the point where it says we
shouldn't be pushing this opportunity to
its full extent.
I believe the way to go at this is to
think big and certainly Google self
driving cars and Google alphabet
are thinking very big in this space.
Start small. 13 Prius says, get out
and start learning on public roads.
Learn fast.
We've been learning fast now for almost
a decade and it's been extraordinary
insights and then scale smart.
I don't think anyone's going to
want to scale a system that has the
vulnerabilities that,
that you're concerned with.
We're going to have to
have solutions to that.
Should that be the first problem
to fix? I don't know. I, you know,
I don't think solving snow storms on
Loveland pass at nighttime was the first
thing to work on. And driverless
cars, we may never solve that one,
but I think we've got to get out there
and learn. So I have one more question.
One more please.
Oh, okay. So just where does it
start in a big way. I mean, uh,
you know,
of course it makes sense to focus on the,
the desired end state of, of changing
the car experience for Americans.
But uh, it does it actually start in
some more limited domain, I dunno,
long haul trucking or enthusiasts or
early adopters or CD centers where there's
restricted access for other
kinds of vehicles or what?
Yeah, I think those use cases are
very exciting places to start.
A gated communities, campuses,
those speed applications.
The interesting thing about over the road
trucking is not all freeway links are
created the same. Some are flat, um,
straight, nice weather,
low traffic density,
much easier to get started with his
business. Then some of the curve,
you're a higher traffic area
so it's not going to be just,
we suddenly take it and deploy it on a
large scale in a major metropolitan area.
I think you're going to see a whole
bunch of these smaller plays done. Uh,
as we work hard. No one's saying we're
ready to commercialize this at scale.
What we are saying is we believe that
technology is reaching a point where
there's commercial
consumer value to be had.
And I think with any startup,
you want to get to that point.
You want to get real customers want to
get real money coming in that that's what
we're in the business to do. But I think
these opportunities to talk about are,
are there. Great. Okay. Thanks
so much. Thanks everybody.
[inaudible].